fighting tax evasion and fraud is high
on the EU finance ministers political
agenda today at their meeting in
Brussels they agreed to introduce a
binding antabuse clause in the parent
subsidiary directive this directive aims
at ensuring that profits made by
companies based in more than one member
state are not taxed twice but it has
been abused by certain corporate groups
to avoid paying taxes in any member
state this clause will prevent misuse of
the directive and ensure greater
consistency in its application to
different member states to help member
states clamp down on tax fraud and tax
evasion ministers also decided to extend
the scope of the automatic exchange of
information between tax authorities to
include interest dividends and account
balances the dual aim of this measure is
to prevent taxpayers from hiding capital
abroad or from hiding assets on which
tax is due whilst also improving the
efficiency of tax collection a third
important agreement was reached to
implement regulation defining the
contributions and be paid by banks to
the EU single resolution fund the fund
is to be used in cases of bank failure
and it's a key element of the single
resolution mechanism finally ministers
also discussed the Commission's 315
billion euro investment plan to
kick-start the European economy over the
next three years the plan will be
submitted to EU leaders for approval
when they meet next week in Brussels
director